大変お待たせ致しました
エンディング発表会！！
本当に大変お待たせ致しました
(泣き声)
Fooo↑↑
いつでしたっけ
もう遠い昔のように感じます
２０１６年の４月４日
私はエンディング動画に飽きてしまった
エンディング動画に飽きてしまって
エンディング動画の募集をかけたところ
なんと、ありがたいことに、なんと
２１００個ものエンディング動画をいただきました！
ありがとうござい、あぁぁぁ！！！！
本当にありがとうございます
この動画を出したとき当初はですね
もう本当に動画作るのって大変なんで
なんか多くても１００個ぐらいかなと思ってんですけど
もう本当にありがたいことに
２１００個もの動画を送っていただきまして
僕の想像をはるかに超える量で
こんなに時間がかかってしまいました
本当に遅くなって申し訳ないです
これたぶん僕だけじゃなくて
UUUMの人とかほかの人に手伝ってもらって
協力してみれば結構すぐ終わったものだと思ったんですけど
まぁエンディング動画って言うのは僕のチャンネルのエンディングなので
やっぱり僕のために作ってもらったので
責任をもって僕自身が
すべてのエンディング動画を見ることに意味があると思ったので
応募してくださった動画は僕が一人で全部責任をもって全部見ました
なかなかね、こう時間が取れなくて
なんとか空いてる時間に一日何個でもいいのでちょっとずつ見て
ようやく今日という日を迎えることができました
今回で僕のついにチャンネルの新しいエンディングが決まります
今使っているエンディングがいいという声も多いんですけども
まぁ僕自身が飽きちゃってるんで
これを機にエンディングをバシッ！と変えちゃってもいいのかなと思いました！
まぁこういう感じですべての動画を見させていただいたんですけども
すべての動画に番号を振って
良くも悪くもいいなと思った動画の番号だけピックアップしていきました
良くも悪くもね←ここは重要です
というわけで本当は全部紹介したいんですけれども
そういうわけにもいかないので
僕が選び抜いたこのちょっとすごい！と思った
良くも悪くもね？？
おぉ？！と思った動画、良くも悪くも、おぉ？！動画を今回はみんなで見ていきましょう！
僕もまだどれにするかっていうのは決めてないんで
今回でちゃんと見て決めようと思います
本当にもう４ヶ月かけてやった動画だからさ
頑張った俺！！
みんなありがとう！！
では行こう！！
まずは１個目です
もうこんな感じでどんどん見ていきますよ。次行きましょう
おゆまるを使ってたんですよねこれは
ｗｗ
主役がおゆまるみたいになってますね
もうなんかねチャンネルの趣旨が変わっちゃってますね
ホラーチャンネルみたいになってるんですよね
いや、最後！
最後完全におかしいでしょ
えぇ？！
これねすごいよくできてるなと思ったんですよね
うん
シンプル！
こういうのは僕好きです結構
「フィン(Fin)」ってそっちか！
おっ、おっ
これすごいんすよね
なんか
手描きというか手作り感がすごいなって思いました
ありがとうございます
次です
不採用！！
もうこれはねぇ
(笑)
顔がもう
完全にサイコパス
おうおうおうおうおう
すごい！
これはすごいな
うまいと思いました
おぉ…
すげえわ
おお
なんか文字の出し方が、こう
うまいんすよね
次行きまっしょう
(笑)
両サイドが
違いますよ
もう誰のチャンネルかわかんなくなってきちゃってるからね
おぉ〜
パッと出る感じがすごい
プッ
あんなマリルリのアソコだけこうなるおもちゃなんてあるんですね
次
ひとこと
おお〜うまいうまい
(拍手)
ここに前回の動画を入れるっていう作戦ですね
このあとは良くできてんだけどね〜
なんで最初にもやし持ってきたかなあ
おっ
いいよ
いいよ！
(驚)
よく回ったねあんなに
わぁ
お～
おお～！
木彫り状態のやつだ
これすごいよね
(笑)
ど、どうした？？
すっげえ臨場感がハンパないっすよ
うわ～
至近距離でも美しいっすね
おお～いいよいいよ
ねこちゃんが…
おお！
いやぁほんとよくできてるよ
結局高評価かいｗ
いや、俺じゃないからね？
怒られちゃうよ、俺が…
落ち着いてるね
いいよ
やっちまったな
不採用
いやーすごいうまいうまいよくできてる
次です
かわいい
？！
うわ～～～～～～～～～～！！！！！！
不採用
うわ～すげー
かっけー
かっこいい
ありがｔしんじー/SHIN-Gさんありがとうございます
バナナでFINって書いてあった
めっちゃバナナで
もうこれツイッターなどで完全にう○こじゃねーか
ほかのバナナとかもうなんか全体てきになんかもう
おれのアイコンにもち○こみたいになってんじゃん
下ネタばっかり
不採用！
カエルだ
あらー
ヤンキーみたいになっちゃってんじゃん
くまのスライムバージョン
おー！ダークネス
なんでこの画像にした？ｗ
こわれちゃった
この曲みんな好きなのね
まあでもすげえきれいだな
すげえすげえすげえありがとうございます
Na
うまい
よくまとまってる
うまいなみんなほんとに
びっくりしたー
オレ轢かれてんじゃん
すげえうまいな
おーよくできてるすごいすごい
かっこいいな
うおーー！なにさいごの？！
finish!
もう僕の情報が詳しくのってますねここに
次の方はこの方はですね音楽なんですよね
音楽をつくってた方々です
いやすげーよ
映像の時は他のを採用してBGMのこのひとのこのちょっとなめた音楽で
採用って言うのもちょっとありかなと思ってます
つｇ
そことそこ！！
これはもうおこられるよー
おいおいおい
なんでここ採用した？ｗ
すごい
なにこのーファミコンっというか
このかんじ好きなんすよぼく　すげえ
うわ目がうごいてる
すごいんだよなこのクオリティが
いいかんじいいかんじ
なんでみんな裸のやつ使うのかなー？
すげー
すごいすごいシンプル
おーかわいい
すごいうまい
すげえなーおしゃれだなー
さいご－
3Dだ
民族感のある音楽でしたね
かっけー
すごいよねクオリティが
やべえなこれは
うわーうまいうまいうまい
すごい
ととのってるなー
走ってるー
すげーなー
もうなんかアニメーションですよねここまでくると
まって！すごすぎでしょこれ！
うーーーーーーーわっ
これは俗にいう
才能の無駄遣いです
くちがわれちゃってじゃん
えーきもいきもいきもいきもいけどーすごいっす
かっこよ
オレじゃないよー
シンプルで好きですこういうの
ゲームボーイ感が
すげー
なんかアニメ調が好きなんすよけっこう
おわり
おいおいばかばかばかばかやめろやめろ
いやチャンネル登録よろしこじゃないからほんとに
コマンドタイプだ
すげー戦ってるねー
共有してね
すげえ
よくこんなの作れるなーておもいますよ
/ゴキ\
すげーーー
ばなろばまたち○こでてきたよ
マイクラですねー
あーー
死んでしもうた
何なのこいつの採用率高くね？
空飛ぶカエル
G(ゴ○ブリ)もいるじゃん
実はねまだやっと半分ぐらいなんですけども
もうねどっちかというとねー
後半にもねなかなかすごい人たちが多かったんで
後半もかなり見どころあると思います
後半
すごいから
エンディング
字幕作成 安川輝  tomon9086  hachiperia 今日の一言 たけ  ynitkt  0777hmajjDEMO  で、お送りしました。
後半お楽しみに 遂に新ED決まります。NEXTmovie